from the brilliant mind that brought you
the martian
in the face of overwhelming odds i'm
left with only one option
i'm gonna have to science the out
of this
[Music]
and the smash follow-up hit artemis
comes a spectacular new work of fiction
that can only be described as
his best work ever project hail mary is
a tale of discovery
speculation and survival to rival the
martian and artemis
a dripping tale of survival facing
humanity our galaxy
gripped in the throes of battle with an
invisible
interstellar enemy ravaging
our son our earth
hangs in the balance and only
one man awakening from a coma
in the midst of interstellar space
is charged with a suicide mission
save earth save humanity sacrifice
himself
and do it all and his own wits
a propulsive adventures a yarn spun
the way only weir can do
once again proving andy weir is a
singular talent
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
today's very special guest it's andy
weir
joining us from a location i assume up
north in california andy
yeah that's right and hi thanks for
having me yeah i'm in saratoga
california which is
kind of near san jose it's in the san
francisco bay area
it's a pleasure to welcome you back we
met a couple times when you were back
uh i can't say it's your alma mater
right there must be some word for
for uh when you didn't graduate but uh
you know i think you uh you've done okay
even though you didn't graduate i do
want to talk about our relation your
relationship to ucsd
and stuff like that later but i want to
introduce you andy weir
uh author of many many wonderful
works of art and science fiction
including
artemis including the martian egg
and this book project hail mary which
i'll have my producer hold up
on the screen i listened to it i read it
in digital advanced copy form
and uh it's a it's a book about a
teacher uh who turns
into an astronaut and then wakes up on a
spaceship
with amnesia and realizes up to him to
save the world from an algae
that's eating the sun now andy i don't
want to give away a spoiler but it's
almost impossible not to so i'm just
going to say
if you don't want the spoiler just you
know plug your ears for one second
but uh darth vader is luke skywalker's
father i'm sorry
i'm sorry it's time you knew
and leah is the sister of luke i'm so
sorry to give it away but
um it's it's actually you know i love
this book i think it's your best book i
i know you're probably you're tired of
hearing it but uh
but you're right hearing
but the thing that that really i love
about this book i've listened to
all you know all three of your uh three
of your most famous books the martian
artemis
and this book uh i think the spoiler
grace period is at least
a year so people you know um they
haven't listened to the to the uh red
artemis or the martian too bad for you
guys but
um because we might we might spoil those
books really thoroughly
but i love listening to the books so the
last uh before this one i listened to
this one this is phenomenal
um and actually i think this one you
almost have to listen to it so even if
you buy it please buy the audio copy too
because
yes buy both kinds i appreciate that uh
and the hard copy hardcover copy
and then also just mail me some cash
please
vetmo too andy weir
um so what was the process like of the
audiobook this time i'll just say that
there's
an incredible amount of audio
engineering and i want to talk to you
about that about
communication because that plays a huge
role in this book not only the science
but also linguistics
plays a huge role in it i've had on uh
stephen wolfram who played a big role in
arrival
and um and the linguistics behind that
um how hard and challenging was it to
record the audiobook this time you
didn't read it but you were
deeply involved in it yeah i was
involved in audible
well they went through a whole bunch of
clever stuff uh figured out
uh it's narrated by the incredibly
talented uh roy
ray porter who is of course
just awesome top-tier audiobook narrator
there
and um yeah they they came up with uh
you know after going back and forth and
trying out a few things they came up
with um
what i think is a pretty good way of
dealing with that challenge
that the story presents in the audio
retelling and i think they did a great
job in how they approached it
i'm trying not to get too spoilery i
mean i know that we're
i mean you're probably going to warn
your listeners oh okay here there be
spoilers but
there's kind of i would say two layers
of spoiler in this
book there's the normal spoilers that
okay well you're gonna learn about this
stuff in the first couple of chapters
anyway
and then there's like an you know epic
spoiler that
happens uh about 120 pages into the book
that you probably don't want to have
ruined for you
yeah exactly the um the main character
of course in this book is a teacher and
the first place i want to start off
uh after moving from the uh from the
very multi-talented uh
narration of the audiobook which
narrates not only you know there are
female characters male 2
characters of course your previous book
artemis was narrated by rosario dawson
which was just uh the like i've had a
run of really good narrators
like i've had um rc brave was the
original martian narrator
and then um and then it got re-recorded
with will wheaton
that's the narrator and that was just
because the um
the rights to the to the bray recording
expired and so audible needed to make a
new recording
um then uh then of course rosario dawson
narrated artemis and then you know uh
reporter for this so it's awesome
crown that leads for better narrators
the main character
uh is it astronaut uh grace who becomes
a um who becomes an unwitting
and uh hero in the story uh as an
astronaut as you'll find out
um and uh and he has amnesia i don't
think that's too much of a spoiler that
comes in very early in the book it's
like
right away that's right i don't want to
spoil page one but uh there you go
i feel like that one's okay i feel like
you know there's this
canard that those who you know who can
do do and those who can't do teach and
here i am a college professor at your
work did you ever have a teacher you
know and what you did
and and then that taught you what you do
or uh do you feel like you're pretty
much
self-made and a lot of what you're
becoming successful at
well i mean i guess i'm self-taught on
most of the science stuff just because
it's something that's always been
interesting to me but
um i had i certainly had teachers
especially in high school
that were really influential and kind of
fostering my interest of that
so i'll make a special shout out to mr
fong from livermore high school
his name is nelson fong and uh mrs cox
and uh mr nicola who was actually my
history teacher but he just made it
really interesting
yeah i think the depth of uh
scholasticism
here in the book you know i was actually
just teaching my cosmology upper
division cosmology class and i was
telling them
you know again i have struggled you know
coming up with the name for what you are
and how you relate to this
unifying university besides epic donor
and i want to thank you
for the weird uh for the weir airport uh
we needed that
yes yeah spaceport sorry
oh sure um
but it was uh you know really ripped
from from a lot of modern headlines and
we're talking about things today in my
cosmology class
that you can measure the distance to an
object using many different ways you can
measure it using a ruler you can measure
it using
the angular diameter that it subtends
and you can measure it using the
luminance that it emits if it's emitting
luminance and the inverse square law
and of course all these you know our
tools are used in cosmology
but i think what i love about your books
including the martian which i made
you know required reading for my
students my graduate students when they
go down to chile in the atacama desert
at seventeen thousand feet
which makes a tiny appearance in this
book by the way
yeah they mentioned the observatory yeah
that's right that's right and i want to
invite you by the way i want to invite
you to the simon's observatory at 17
200 feet in the atacama desert probably
not doing that but okay
a little bit middle of nowhere-ish for
my tastes
well it's one of the places nasa does go
to simulate the martian environment
uh but anyway yeah the resourcefulness
of the characters
and i know that you're a tinkerer you
reputed to have
still have all of your digits even
though you have a circular saw that you
use to make
different objects in your in your home
workshop i think there's some kind of
3d printer maybe behind you i don't know
that's a laser cutter but yeah
okay so still that even more impressive
you have all your
and eyeballs fingers i have a rule in my
lab i have a sign that says don't look
into the laser with your remaining
uh yeah so was this always natural to
you were you exposed to
not to lasers but were you exposed to
like curiosity
tinkering spirit building clocks
building stuff were you exposed to that
by
uh by these mentors that you just gave
shout outs to or did it come naturally
to you
uh that came naturally to me i've just
always had an interest in that sort of
you know i really like mechanical
systems which is funny because i don't
really write about them
but um uh yeah yeah just
just the way things work
has always been really fascinating to me
um
and so uh thinking about the book you
know i heard an interview with my friend
matt kaplan who's a member of the
planetary society
mary radio he's actually coming to
interview me next week here at ucsd
he's a friend um and he was saying you
know that uh
it's what's remarkable about you is that
you uh you have this confidence you have
this thorough
you know research ability which would
make a great graduate student or you
know a research scientist
but you also are not afraid to just say
you know effort i'm just going to make
stuff up
and have neutrinos store you know energy
how do you
how do you balance the like the hard
science where you'll get the exact cause
i look these things up andy you know
i look up the the wavelength and i
actually have these memorized you know
what wavelength lines of the infrared
the co2 absorb at
this is pertinent to the book that's not
a spoiler right there's two right
yeah it was in the petrova line you know
which which
it doesn't exist but anyway but then
neutrino story how do you balance that
as a hard science fiction author how do
you balance the realism
with the like just sometimes i'm gonna
say f it and just just make it up
well i mean usually i have to make
something up usually i have to
do something but i want it to be as
inobtrusive as possible i want it to be
i don't want to you know just give a
ship a warp drive or anything like that
i want to i want to
minimize the violations to physics that
i have to do
in the case of project ailmary it's like
you have to go all the way down to the
quantum level literally before you find
where i was hand waving
and actually you can use neutrinos to
store mass the problem is you can't
store neutrinos and so that's the part
that i made up
you you could use neutrinos and the
neutrinos really are their own
antiparticle
if you do manage to get two neutrinos to
whack into each other
then they would create two photons in
this infrared band of wavelength
right yeah of course uh you know
neutrinos were proposed they were almost
in the 1930s wolfgang powell we proposed
them
and then for a string of years there
were nobel prizes whenever these new
particles would be awarded and then
famous isadora rabbi said
uh i propose that a nobel prize goes to
the man who does not discover
a new particle this year yeah
too many of them um so when we're
looking at yeah so there has to be some
level of plausibility
but is there ever you know something
where thinking in the back of your mind
you know like uh i might be going too
far or do you feel like you've earned
enough credibility
with just your sheer dogged you know
research ability
that it doesn't matter basically
well i mean i i hope i haven't gone too
far but yeah i always try
to keep it pretty minimal in terms of
invasiveness you know to physics so i
never really think i've gone too far
because i kind of if anything i spend
too much time and effort going
further down the rabbit hole than i need
to where i could have just hand waved
much earlier and nobody would have
objected you know
now this book as i said in the very
beginning the only a minimal kind of
intro to it that i can you know
basically there's some form of
life that uh is is afflicting uh
the sun and it's causing massive
destruction now
this not only taps into our global
pandemic that we're experiencing
it has resonance no pun intended with
global warming etc
um were all these things you know kind
of going through your mind i mean did
when did you start this project was it
pre-covered 19 on the horizon or
did how was it with regard to the
pandemic and certainly global warming
has been around for a long time right
um right so i come i finished the entire
book before covet 19 struck
so any any correlation between the book
and the pandemic is pure coincidence
um so you know there are some things
that seem to be parallels but
i finished the whole thing before the
pandemic so there's nothing like that
um intentional as for global warming or
climate change
um i never have any sort of meaning or
or message or moral in my stories um
in this case it's not climate change
it's not like
man-made climate change it's not co2
emissions it's literally
an alien algae growing on the surface of
the sun
that is now absorbing enough of the
sun's luminance
that earth itself is in danger because
it just is not getting enough energy
from the sun and if anything the there's
even just a
weird thing in the book that um the
global warming is now what they want
to have happen like because the earth is
not getting enough energy so we want to
retain
the energy that we are getting and make
it make it stay a little longer
and so they're deliberately doing things
to increase global warming
right and uh when you look through the
the scientific method plays a huge role
in the book and many of the heroes in
the book are scientists
and and uh and and even you know sort of
the
military industrial complex is playing a
role because you have to mobilize you
know kind of planetary resources to do
that
um to what level suspension of disbelief
would come in there
do you feel like such a thing could be
mobilized do you feel like we saw that
in coven 19 at all i mean
you come out of kovan 19 thinking that
your the scenario
outline in project hair mary is more
plausible or less plausible after what
we've seen in the last 16 months
i would say more plausible because it
kind of validates my
my beliefs that we can pretty much come
together pretty significantly as a
as a species to like fight a common
enemy and
uh yeah i mean of course you know
it's a little bit different because um
in in uh project hail mary it's a
global systemic issue it's it's like
everybody dies if we don't solve this
right you can't it there's nothing
any one country can do to protect just
its citizens
right and that's not the case with covid
each country
can make its own rules and implement its
own strategies for trying to
slow or stop the spread or you know
whatever else so it's a little different
um but i do see an awful lot of
cooperation just in the world in general
um yeah so i'm i'm
i mean obviously we weren't perfect
about it we humanity we weren't perfect
about it and there was some
sloppiness there but uh i don't know i
feel like we're turning a corner on
covid
um the us is now um making
so much vaccine that we're we're now
starting to send it to other countries
um so in this book i find that there's
either something hilarious
um some juicy science nerd nugget
on every page uh even the the table of
contents you know it brought me to tears
that that library
donation i was weeping andy that was
what
and actually the fantastic people the
isbn is just hilarious
you know that was i played the lottery
that number that oh there we go
now now tell me i mean it's not a
spoiler but you dedicate it to john paul
george and ringo why is that um i'm just
a big beatles fan
and there's a lot of like little beatles
um references
in the book so i thought it was oh yes
yes there were stooges references as
well
so that's delightful but i love
personally whenever i get a shout out
you know it's like
and he's talking to me he knows me he
understands me
he knows that i was an amateur
astronomer and amateur astronomers play
a role in this book
and i i think it's it's remarkable i
talked about this name drop alert name
drop alert
i talked to neil degrasse tyson about a
month ago and he was saying
astronomy is one of the few fields where
amateurs play a significant role where
amateurs
are actually doing useful science
they're doing variable star research
they're doing binary star research
and in your book they're saving the
universe yeah
i find with you amateur writers you turn
you weren't a professional writer
you went from amateur to do you see
commonality between are there other
fields of
amateur science or amateur engineering
that seem to convey
you know a certain type of skill set
that's transferable to writing or some
other field
i mean uh i think a lot of amateur uh
software engineering
can quickly turn into a profession and a
lot of a lot of like
um really good software comes out of
people just doing it for the hell of it
not you know working for a company or
anything um
what else is there that's really good um
in some of the newer things like 3d
printing and stuff
um professional companies are getting
very good at it but it was the amateurs
with their little home
kits that kind of worked the kinks out
of the system
figure out how those things worked
that's cool
yeah so there's a lot of things where
you know you can be a quote-unquote
amateur and really have an effect on the
field
also any anything related to art or
entertainment i would say
because you can just be you know good at
this stuff you could be like just
a really good artist and you like make a
good sculpture or a painting or
something
and you could start a trend in the art
world and there you're
an amateur who just changed the field
yeah and and this uh youtube economy
you know mike i've become a creator and
my uh
you know my subscriber really
appreciates it
uh well uh hi hi brian's mom how you
doing
she's my toughest critic you know they
say don't read the comments and i don't
whenever she leaves a comment i do not
read it
um converse of of this you know of the
amateur community is is now prominent
and it's kind of adjacent to your field
in my field in some sense
and that's ufology you know there's tons
of ufologists out there nowadays
and there's a big data dump coming in uh
in just about three weeks
from the time of release of this uh the
pentagon is going to release all this
data
um you must get harassed by you know
tons and tons of
of media requests or what have you asked
about it
do you think that there's there's like
almost the problem of too much data or
garbage in garbage out
danger or do you think it's good and
healthy that so many amateur ufologists
are out there
well i mean i don't believe that we've
ever been visited by any aliens
so let's be clear um but i mean
if people want anything that people do
and take seriously as a science expands
human knowledge
even if it's just to say like yeah i've
confirmed that that thing
wasn't a ufo it was an airplane or that
thing wasn't a ufo it was a reflection
off the camera lens
and so on so there's you know negative
results are just as good as positive
results in terms of
um advancing humankind however i do feel
like ufologists like many
kind of i don't want to be insulting but
pseudosciences
tend to not really follow the scientific
method very well
and they tend to really start with a
conclusion and then really try hard to
work backwards to justify it
and so you'll almost always find some
sort of leap of logic
or some sort of gap in the proof that
just
you know you'd never get away with that
in a scientific paper right
yeah right yeah and that's one of the
contexts that you know
i was hoping we turn to next and and you
actually spoke recently we saw each
other recently you spoke at the seti
institute virtually and i'm one of their
you know minor contributors i haven't
reached the weir level of
the weir airport at the city institute
right
the jill carter helipad
uh yes the um but i gave a talk there a
couple of years back and i said
you know if one of my students handed in
the drake equation i would fail her
or him because it's never presented with
error bars you know it's like
if you hand in an equation or a plot and
it's it's funny because it's like here's
this equation
and it's got 100 percent uncertainty if
you estimate something
that's has a hundred it could be zero it
could be an infinite or ten thousand
alien
and so it shouldn't be so surprising but
one thing i love about this book
you could easily make a version of the
drake equation where uh for each of the
input values you have to specify
error ranges and then you can derive the
error bars
yeah so i do that at my seti institute
talk maybe i'll put a link
here somewhere over there in the video
uh and i do that and i say here's an
example
because one of the solutions to the to
the fermi paradox is that
just as you and i go to the zoo i take
my kids to the zoo that i don't let them
bang on the gorilla cage and you know
and say hey
here we like in other words the aliens
might not want to disturb us right so
they might be here
but they don't disturb us so we don't
know that they're here because we don't
um they're not observable because they
cloak themselves for some reason
and um so i did an estimation i said i'm
from san diego as you used to live here
we have the world famous san diego zoo
and wild animal park
and if you remember we had this
sculpture here on campus with this
netting that's at about 17 feet tall and
i always say that's the catch
escape giraffe in the san diego zoo well
we always called it the koala catchers
when i was there
i always give it as a quiz for the
visiting string theorists that come here
what is that thing here but actually um
so i gave an example
in my study institute i said like how
many how many people are at the san
diego zoo right now and you can go
through the math
and if you don't give an error bar it
could be zero or it could be eight
thousand
no and it's actually close to about
eight thousand but uh but yeah so i
think
i think you're right if you can do
something that expands human knowledge
that it reduces the bayesian confidence
interval it tightens it up
and that's a good that's a service and
one thing i love about
your um your your your book and and all
your books is that you
you think kind of like an alien like in
other words
you're kind of coming in uh and one of
those fellow human i know that you are
speaking in just for i am a human like
you
i love metabolizing protocol
mitochondrial krebs cycle violation
i i love breathing oxygen
uh we too should exchange long protein
strands to communicate
um uh so uh one
one thing i've thought about and has
been in the astronomical community is
where should we look so one of my
colleagues upstairs professor shelly
wright
she studies optical study and one thing
in the book that you
make quite prominent use of is that
these these algae
you know have a signature and that you
know perhaps other
civilizations might also know about that
signature do you think we've been going
about seti
the wrong way in other words like should
we look for extraterrestrials using
some kind of universal signature of that
we are aware of
i i mean or are we you know should we
look uh as broadly as possible
i mean well i mean i'm hardly qualified
to comment on that and
much smarter people than me have already
worked all those questions through at
citi but
don't they kind of do that with the
hydrogen line i mean yeah there's a 21
centimeter line but of course that's a
radio line and it's
you know not as powerful perhaps as an
optical line or you know something like
that
or as the petrova line perhaps yes oh
yeah um
but yeah by the way just uh calling back
to earlier in the discussion
uh my answer to the fermi paradox
is um not the cloaking devices or
anything like that
my answer is i believe there is probably
you know just
looking at the drake equation there's
probably intelligent life out there
but i also believe we will never be able
to go faster than light
nor transfer nor transmit ener nor
transmit information
faster than light so i think that
they're you know
if it turns out that the nearest
intelligent life form is a thousand
light years away
like if they're looking at us with a
super advanced telescope right now
they're seeing
like the way things were in the year you
know
10 21 and if we said hi
right now it would take 2 000 years to
get a response you know
so i'm just um i just that my answer to
the fermi paradox is
the inviolability of the speed of light
yeah yeah that is uh certainly not only
a good idea as einstein said but the law
yeah so uh
yeah maybe while we're selling that
topic of aliens i know that's not not
really a focus of the book
you know it's in in the large scheme of
things let me just say have you thought
about these you know kind of epic
battles between you know the stephen
hawkings and the
and the elon musk's of the world and in
terms of like the great filter and
and you know should we should we respond
if we get a message you know tomorrow
uh just because they won't know about us
you know it doesn't mean that there
isn't a beam of
light coming towards us right now with
some information should we respond or a
talking said
you know that would be like ringing the
dinner bell saying uh i'm ready for
i'm ready for you now for dinner i have
no idea
how to answer that because it's all just
wild speculation
um but i i would think if if
i mean i would want to answer
[Laughter]
so uh we talked a little bit about uh
some of the connections
uh in the book between um you know or
rather in your past between your
upbringing et cetera i think you
read some of your father was a particle
physicist is that right yeah well
i mean in your mind my mom was an
engineer um i say
particle physicist generally because
it's easier than explaining the truth
which is
he was a linear accelerator physicist um
so he worked with electrons a lot but i
mean he didn't do
stuff with like you know neutrinos or
muons or anything like that but uh
but yeah that's what he did and he's not
dead by the way he's just retired that's
why i say past tense on he was
yeah i presume
what's that was that was that slack i
presume up up in the basement no it
wasn't at slac it was an ata
which was um a program run through uh
lawrence livermore
oh really oh wow oh very interesting
okay
um so i'm gonna talk about language i've
had on um as i said stephen wolfram
and also noam chomsky and in both of
those gentlemen we talked a lot about
alien communication
and how how one would communicate with
an alien of course in arrival
uh there's an alien species that comes
to earth and
uh and and uh actually communicates
directly through the spaceship with amy
adams character and
um and then the not wonderful novel by
ted chang
and uh and then of course noam chomsky
has thought a lot about communication
but always there's
a gestural aspect to it and in fact as
you
probably know nom nom thinks that there
is a
basically a component of language
communication
that is inherently um kind of uh physio
somatic or something like that that you
that you basically need some way of
communicating using your hands or
something
what do you think about communication
how would you communicate with an alien
species
if you just got a beam of morse code
could you communicate with an alien
species
you think or how would you how would you
crack that particular nut or
how do you resolve such things well any
communication you have you would have to
send
something that hopefully they would be
able to um
identify as a key on what what
things mean right and so uh
i don't i i don't know exactly how you
would go about doing that
but it would be difficult for sure and
working out a common language requires
pretty much
near instant communication like you
and the other party like if if you
you know if you don't speak a word of
like you know cantonese
and you're talking to a cantonese
speaker who doesn't speak a word of
english
if you're just like locked in a cell
together you guys will
over the course of probably a day have a
little bit of a shared language
but you you work that stuff out with
communication you point at yourself and
say your name you point at the
you point the floor and say floor and
stuff like that and so
it has to go back and forth and back and
forth if there are two
species communicating across a
thousand-year gulf you're looking at
hundreds of thousands of years before
they even start getting a shared
language going
right that's the so-called chinese room
argument that says
a digital computer in another it's a
version of the
total different than the challenger the
chinese room argument
is just um you can't tell the difference
between
if a computer understands something or
is just
regurgitating a pre-ordained list of
responses
um this is like aliens actively
attempting to understand
and collaboratively create a language
but it would still
take a really long time if the
conversation
takes you know has to happen over the
over late years
uh i want to turn now to the craft of
writing and that
will take us to maybe some rapid fire
and then we'll uh move into some other
other domains if you have uh if you have
the time and then we'll wrap up with my
ipad yeah before we do that i just need
to hit the bathroom i'll be right back
sorry yeah let me pause
zoom that okay great okay
so now we're gonna get into the practice
of writing
all right okay so um first of all i'll
do one i'll do one rapid fire question
um true or false or yes or no
is the best way to sell your nth
book to write your n plus one book
i don't really understand that question
[Music]
let's say you you wrote you wrote the
project hail mary and you want to make a
really
great success to you i've heard that the
best way to to
you know kind of get attention and and
get get uh
publishers and sell more books is to
write your next book
uh yeah i've never heard that theory
before uh i would disagree with it
[Laughter]
okay uh next question semi-rapid fire
is um do you always write a book
now with kind of the idea of a movie
production coming down
the pike no i uh i i and i think that
now my style of writing tends to be kind
of cinematic
cinematic because i see it in my head
like that but i'm not deliberately
trying to make it movie friendly
and that's because my job is to write a
book if i want to write
and this is what i tell other writers
who are asking for advice if you want to
write a movie write a movie
write a screenplay no problem but if if
if if what you really want in the end
here is a movie then write a movie
um if you're going to write a book write
a book don't sacrifice
good plot ideas or good narrative
techniques because you think it wouldn't
translate well into a film
and what about uh artemis what's the
status of the movie
artemis artemis is um
the the screenwriter uh geneva robertson
voret is working on the screenplay
uh she's already made a few revs and
sent them to um the directors
we have the directors phil lord and
chris miller attached um
and uh that's kind of the status of
where it is right now
and we have some artists working on um
you know what what the inside of artemis
could look like
and you know some of the storyboarding
that sort of thing
and i understand that uh ryan gosling
is attached in some way to uh project
hail mary's movie adaptation
yeah that's right um for project hail
mary mgm bought the film rights
and ryan gosling is attached to play the
lead ryan
ryland grace oh yes that's right so the
lead character's name is ryland grace
not to be confused with ryan gosling who
is
gonna play him um also like artemis this
is also set to be direct by phil lord
and chris miller
uh we have drew goddard working on the
screenplay he's though
he's the guy who did the screenplay
adaptation of the martian so
obviously his skills speak for
themselves and
uh mgm is really seems pretty excited
about it
so i feel like it's got a good chance of
being greenlighted we'll see
you never really know with hollywood and
is that pretty hands off like would you
be in but would you go down would you be
involved in it or would you just be work
uh well i mean i am involved in uh
project hail mary i'm actually a
producer on the film
so yeah but uh
the the reason i'm a producer is um so
that i could have some
some of the front-end gross um
just money-wise and so uh i'm
my main objective is to stay out of the
way of the real producers
but the end result is i am involved in a
lot of these decisions
i'll offer my opinions but i try not to
make ways or get in anybody's way
right right um next up
i have uh let's see
um okay do you write every day do you
have like a writing target
thousand words a day do you have any
kind of writing schedule daily
habits rituals when i when i'm working
on a first draft i try to make a
thousand words per week day
or more accurately i try to make 5 000
words a week with minimum levels so
the system i came up with is like by the
end of monday i need to have a thousand
words written by the end of tuesday i
need to have 2 000 words written for the
week
wednesday 3 000 and so on all the way up
to 5000 for friday
that system i kind of worked out over
time
that way if i'm if i'm if it's like a
monday and i'm plugging along and i blow
through a thousand words
i'm not encouraged to stop right
i'll just keep going and say now i'm
working off tuesday's debt you know
so um that's that's the system i came up
with although right this moment i'm just
kind of free form
messing around working on the research
for my next book so
i'm not writing yet do you have any
other rituals
meditation exercise sport biathlon
hunting big game big game hunting
not no not quite so much uh no no big
game hunting
no rituals just just plugging along
just doing the work huh i'm a much more
boring guy than people suspect
yeah no that's that's uh that's well it
comes across but it's a good thing i
think it's
okay rather than you're like uh living
like hemingway and then uh you know
meeting an untimely end uh okay best
part and worst part about being
a writer professional writer well the
best part of course is that you're your
own boss you get to
yeah and also it's one of the few
creative
jobs where you're basically a dictator
i mean aside from a site from your
editor you know
giving you notes and stuff you are the
sole arbiter of what does and doesn't go
into the story
if you're in film well there's a whole
bunch of people who get input there's
the
the you know the the screenwriter the
director the performers often have
things to say the studio and so on
but when you're a writer of a novel it's
just you
so that's kind of cool the downside is
is you have to motivate yourself
there's no one breathing down your neck
i mean sometimes if you have a contract
then your editor might give you a call
but
um for the most part the the bad part of
being self-directed is you have to also
be self-motivated and that can be
difficult
and i also miss having a team of people
that i work with because i came from
software originally
and i miss like going to work i miss
well of course everybody does right now
but
even before the pandemic i i missed
going to work i missed being part of a
team i missed
you know that environment that
camaraderie that comes with it i
i really enjoyed my job as a software
engineer and the last
engineering job i had before i left i i
liked it i really enjoyed it and i
i hung on there much longer than i
needed to just because
i liked the work i liked my co-workers
so i missed that i think one of the most
surprising things in the book is how
prominent and important
the role of microsoft excel is in this
book
and uh yeah go ahead
uh yeah uh ryland ends up using excel a
lot to keep track of a bunch of data
yeah it made me think of one of the
dirtiest secrets in the publishing
business i i
assume for you too is that uh much of
publishing is accomplished by emailing
microsoft word documents across the
country with track changes
is that true or small absolutely
no doubt about it there's got to be a
better way uh come on andy we got to
figure out a better way
i'm sure they're i'm not sure there's a
better way though because
like it's a really efficient way attract
changes
is track changes in the comments and the
notes and stuff like that that's a
really good way of
of doing uh editing passes with multiple
people involved um so i've got no
complaints with it
yeah it's just yeah maybe they could be
there could be yeah there could be maybe
a more secure way to pass the document
around
yeah and then real-time updating or
collaboration or something like that
i don't know i mean you could do that
with google docs if you really wanted
but yeah i don't need to
see each individual letter show up
you know at the moment my editor is
writing a message on the thing it's okay
and and also um it's best if i don't see
anything until he's done
and re-read them and sent it along right
there's a lot of mid-air collisions you
could have where he writes a comment and
then decides no i don't want to say that
but i've already seen the comment now
i'm working on it you know
i guess in the non-fiction world you
know where you're like writing a chapter
that's standalone you
you want to like compile you know and
just separately write chapters and then
compile the whole thing i don't want to
email you know 80 000 words every time i
change a word in a chapter but
that's a small thing what about you
narrating an audiobook any any inkling
to do that ever
no i don't think so um i'm uh you know
i i don't consider myself a particularly
good voice actor
and also um the the narrators
that we've been getting from my books
are just fantastic
i mean so why would i ever want to
displace
any of them i mean like these are top
tier narrators so
i i hope that trend continues yeah
okay uh next um
best and worst writing advice you've
ever
uh received well the best writing advice
uh well i mean at the risk of sounding
douchey i think the best writing advice
is the piece that i came up with
which is um don't tell your friends and
family your story idea
well you could tell them the basic idea
but don't tell them the details of the
story
because it satisfies your need for an
audience and saps your will to actually
write it
so that's that's a good piece of advice
um
let's see bad writing advice
um yeah i don't know i'm having a hard
time thinking of any bad writing advice
i know i do know some people who are
like oh i like to write the fun
scenes first and then back fill in with
the intermediate with the connective
tissue kind of scenes
and i think that's a terrible idea
because you'll write all the fun scenes
and then you have nothing but miserable
work ahead of you
and so you won't do it so you'll never
finish
that's what i always tell my students
whenever they like solve something i go
congratulations now you've earned your
ticket to an even harder problem
exactly um do you feel
like you've achieved what uh neil
degrasse tyson and i
we discussed as like niche fame like he
in
time says he can't even go on the subway
with a mask on you know like yeah
like he's too famous you you are you
just famous enough do you feel like you
get recognized your trademark
chapeau glasses and
no i mean i don't get recognized that
much that's the cool thing about being a
writer you're famous when you want to be
um yeah if i'm at a convention or
something like that i'll get spotted all
the time
you know but if i'm just out in the wild
i mean
maybe once a month someone will
recognize me
that's about it and that that's you know
pre-coveted
back when you know you go to the grocery
store or restaurant or whatever
it'll be rare but it'll happen okay do
you
like or hate getting feedback on bugs
like a uh do you give a bug bounty when
someone one of your readers say one of
my undergraduates finds an
error in your book um i like it i i like
that my readers are engaged enough to be
looking at it at that level and uh you
know
i bring it upon myself because i i tell
everyone hey i write scientifically
accurate science fiction
and they're like really let's see about
that and so i certainly can't whine
if they do hit me with some truth you
know
all right well i got some truth for you
andy you ready yeah yeah
i know a few i know a few that i messed
up all right well you messed up the
countries that use the imperial system
united states there's not two
there's the united states there's
liberia
oh i didn't know liberia there's uh
you do you do have i think you say
liberia but it's liberia
and then there's myanmar and burma okay
now i'm john mara and burma are the same
thing
there's one more typo that so my
undergraduate ben found that one
but i found one that the earth you talk
about magnetic fields in a planet when
you're talking about a certain planet
that shall not be named
right you talk about um planets need a
liquid
uh uh core a molten core
like the earth but the earth has a solid
core oh we have the molten
mantle yes in the whole book
well there's more um there's a an alert
reader
on twitter sent me that at one point he
powers and a
little white led with a like a watch
battery
yeah a watch battery doesn't have enough
voltage to power a white led
or so i was told i have to think about
that the red ones
can be lower but the white ones i guess
need
more high voltage huh uh yeah or or
something like that i mean obviously i
don't know what i'm talking about here
i'm just going off of um
what the guy told me hang on a second i
can i can find only there was a kind of
a world wide web we could look that up
yeah but
who's gonna do that no well i was
actually looking for
um 3.6 volts
yellow is 2.1 volts um
watch battery i'm sure my audience is
going to love it
he says hi i just finished hail mary and
promise a nice 5 star review
40 years of science teaching and only
one quibble you can't light a white led
with one watch battery
uh it needs 3.6 volts minimum so three
three cells in series would do it
so i guess a watch battery has like a
little bit over a volt like one and a
half
volts yeah it has
yeah it has watch battery it depends on
the watch itself
of course the apple i can't have the
apple watch or a cr
uh e32 as three volts yeah anyway
tell them to stuff it tell us what are
you talking
by being meticulously accurate
everywhere where else and claiming that
i'm accurate
that's right i bring this kind of uh
this scrutiny
you are thinking in public and you are
doing what a good scholar should do
which is to be intellectually honest
which is why i knew i could bring up
those two faux pas those fall pause okay
we're coming to the end here andy i
promise
uh and the last thing okay so we talked
about teaching
we talked about um before i get into
okay so would you ever want to be a
professor
would you ever want to teach writing no
uh no i wouldn't want to teach writing
no um but i might want to teach a
science field
i i really like i i don't know there's
something i i really enjoy
explaining science to other people and
so i i
but i'm not i'm not deeply despite what
it appears to be when you're reading my
books i'm not
i'm not really qualified to be like a
you know upper division professor but i
could probably teach like lower division
physics
like like 1a that sort of stuff i could
i could teach those
and those are the names of our physics
classes here at ucsd which brings me to
my last you know major
set of questions so i want to ask you
about that um i don't think
we've ever really communicated about
this if it's not a too painful as a
i had a reader i had a reader i mean i
had a viewer a subscriber
in addition to my mom and he went to
ucsd and i'm not using his name
i didn't say if i could or couldn't so
i'm just not going to but he said he
didn't have a great experience
and he said he wanted to come on my show
anonymously to to talk about why i
didn't have a good experience he was a
physics major
and and he said you know why don't you
ever have on somebody like me and i said
well you know what i'm going to have on
someone who dropped out of ucsd
i'm going to ask him the following
question and i'm going to ask you andy
what what could we have done differently
you know is there something that we
could have done we have vast resources i
don't care
we're a public universe we're building
40-story dormitory with
ocean view and everything we have
resources just because we're a public
university i'm a public servant
i believe it's my responsibility to
taxpayers to to teach and educate
california's students um what could we
have done better for
for a student like you to i i think
it's not me it's you i think um
basically i was at a point in my life
where i just wasn't really to put it
really willing to put out the effort i
had
like a lot of semi-smart people i
breezed through high school
without really having to do any work at
all like it was so easy for me
and then you get to college and it's
like it's real work
and i never learned good study habits i
never learned
any of that stuff and so it was just
really hard for me
now ostensibly the reason i left was
because i ran out of money
and that's true i did i ran out of money
i couldn't afford to go there anymore
um but i mean if i
if i had been working diligently toward
a goal and i've been making
you know getting good grades and was
feeling like i was making progress and i
probably would have found a way to make
it happen
student loans or something else so i
guess for me i just didn't feel
like super directed i didn't feel like
um i just wasn't in a mindset to really
put the effort into college
also remember i was in computer science
and at the time
the tech boom was just beginning and so
there was also an economic thing i was
like
i could either go deeply into debt to
continue
this and get a college degree or i can
immediately right now
start making a decent salary because no
one in the tech industry seems to care
if you have a degree
also so i i don't think there's anything
ucsd could have done differently
although one thing you know at the time
i was there i'm sure things are
different it's been a million years but
at the time i was there
um the the cs department was like
woefully behind
the times in terms of what it taught
like
we've moved around up to cobol or now
okay that's right
glad to hear it yeah no whatever we
teach excel exclusively excellent
no but when i was there um in a world
that was all
basically uh c plus and java
at ucsd they didn't have any classes for
c
plus no classes for java they had one
class for c
straight c and it was an elective and
um mainly they taught pascal very proud
of having invented pascal so they kept
teaching it
way too long um you know and so
those are those are some factors also i
i also think that um
in general in this country people are a
little too obsessed with college degrees
or acquiring them they're not as needed
for employment as people seem to think
and it's so expensive to get one it's
just like
don't go horribly into debt
that's going to take you half your life
to pay off just to get an
art history degree so you can become the
regional manager of sales at some
company
you can go straight into the sales job
you know it's like
and there are tons and tons of
professions out there
that where you don't go to college you
go to a trade school
and these are not like these are
critical
parts of society i mean we need
mechanics we need locksmiths we need
plumbers we need all these things and
you don't
go to college for those so you don't i
don't know there's there's some sort of
notion that college makes you
properly educated and somehow better
than
those who don't have college degrees and
i don't i don't like that
and i guess finally i would say this is
not nothing directed at ucsd this is all
colleges
for me higher education should be i am
investing in my future
i'm paying an institution money so that
they will teach me the skills i need
to go out and be able to demand a higher
salary in the job market
like i'm going to learn i'm going to
learn how to do something most people
don't know how to do
so that i can get paid a good salary for
doing it right
but colleges are still stuck in frankly
this
you know 18th century gentleman mode of
not really being focused on you know
increasing your skills as a potential
worker
but on giving you this comprehensive
education
and i'm like i can understand that
happening in high school where you get
like a big broad education
because they're trying to bring you up
to speed with what we consider a minimum
amount of knowledge for
an adult in our country but for college
i'm paying you to teach me stuff
so i don't want you if i'm paying you to
teach me how to program computers
i don't want you to say i don't get a
degree until i write a report about
beowulf
you know so i i just uh and i know a lot
of people disagree with me on this
but i don't buy into the comprehensive
education thing
i honestly think all colleges should
work functionally like trade schools
if i go to a college lead in computer
programming that's all i want to hear
about when i'm there
nothing else
yeah very good yeah i agree and i think
colleges are maybe
uh shooting themselves in the foot
because you know eventually it's going
to dawn on people that just as you know
harvard doesn't teach you know so
there's not some special brand of
physics that harvard's learned that
you know i haven't learned yet you know
like some there's a fifth maxwell's
equation that hasn't made its way to the
west coast yet
no we all know the same things we all
teach from the same textbooks
and uh and that means it's very
vulnerable to disruption via
you know technology like in artificial
intelligence like who would you rather
learn
uh electromagnetism from brian keating
or from uh james clark maxwell
and i think as we get more and more like
that the colleges have to differentiate
themselves by the perks and that's why
we have
ocean view dorms here and we have the
andy we're natatorium
you know we have uh you know that's the
only way we can differentiate ourselves
and and
you're absolutely right it should have
elements of
of this but you know it's uh it's it's a
tough nut to crack but i think if
colleges don't rise up to this
you know kind of serving a customer
rather than just like
what this ideal system is as you call it
the 18th century british gentleman
um which which is kind of the modality
it's been stuck in you know maybe even
longer i mean i looked up the first
college ever it was like in bologna and
eight and one thousand
eighty and there's basically some old
dude standing up on a stage scratching a
piece of
rock on another piece of rock and you
know i have a white board now and a
marker and that's it that's the only
thing
oxford was founded in the in the
thousands or eleven hundreds
that's right oxford university is older
than the aztec empire
yeah that's right and almost nothing has
changed there's just you know different
different
disciplines and well i mean they don't
do sacrifices anymore oh you mean oxford
okay yeah they still do sacrifice they
still do
you go to the pitch you'll get uh sir
roger penrose frequent guest on the show
all right last question just before we
go to the final thrilling three
if you could adapt any science fiction
novel into a movie other than your own
andrew uh what would it be and why
this is from my friend jacob kuhn i
think i would go for
probably caves of steel by isaac asimov
um first off it's a really good book
it's in the robots
uh genre you know the three laws of
robotics and stuff like that
and it's the first book in a series so
it'd be cool if they made that movie and
then it was successful and then they
made more
awesome okay andy we are now in the
final
section the so-called thrilling three
where i asked
the thrilling three patented questions
which i patented just a minute ago
please do subscribe and like and comment
on this and go to my website
briankating.com you'll get notes and
resources and get a chance to maybe even
win
and copy of project hail mary this
wonderful new book by today's guest
ucsd attendee uh
year that's a good one right ucsc
attendee
pcsd mega donor okay i've donated a cent
to you guys i don't know why
i know i think i think better relations
is going to come and get me
okay the first one has to do with your
near
future when you reach the so-called
biblical age of 120 years old
what ethical wisdom do you want to put
not your material wealth not your
earthly possessions but what material
wisdom
or values do you want to articulate to
give to future generations
uh as an inheritance for the future
um i don't know it's like
i guess i i would mostly just
pass along like not everyone in the
society can relax and kick back
like you you have to pull your own
weight i guess you have to do your share
of society's work i guess you you have
to
i guess it's an old thing but um
give more than you get i guess
fun fact in the in the bible there's a
commandment to take a day off every week
but people forget that the other command
part of that commitment is you have to
work six days a week
it says you must work six days a week
which some of my kids don't recognize no
i'm just kidding
number two involves an up-and-coming
science fiction writer by the name of
arthur c
clarke just getting started is he
okay you might have somewhat of a career
you might hear of him someday anyway um
you might remember uh 2001 a space
odyssey there are these monoliths these
menacing
vehicles or capsules or whatever that
are
built by some unseen extraterrestrial
species which are eventually discovered
by our solar system by human beings
and the response of the characters to
these messages or warnings kind of
encourages humankind
to progress first they're seeing on the
savannah in africa then on the moon and
floating around in other words
i want to ask you andy if you had an
opportunity to make your monolith
and have it last as a billion-year time
capsule not just years
what would you put on it or in it to
kind of
maybe triumphally declare what humankind
had learned
in our existence probably a bunch of
dick jokes
not fart jokes you know that was the
oldest joke ever okay there we go there
we go yeah
no i don't know i mean to people a
billion years from now they're not going
to be able to learn anything from me so
i think a value of a monolith
from our era would be in learning about
our own culture and our own history
and what we were doing back in this
ancient time so i guess i try to impart
information about
history our history up to the present
and that would be done uh exclusively in
an excel document right
uh lastly now we're going backwards in
time and as you know this arthur c
clarke personality had many laws one of
which
was for every expert there's an equal
and opposite expert
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic and that's
how we open the show
every week on the show i'm going to open
with his actual voice
it's pretty cool we got him to read it
from beyond the grave now we found it
somewhere
here at the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination at uc san diego but
his third law
states the only way of discovering the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little way past them
into the impossible and that's the
origin of the name of my podcast
i want to ask you andy what mysterious
aspect of life
might have perplexed you as a 20 year
old a 30 year old but now makes sense
because
you had the courage to go into the
impossible in other words
what life advice would you give to your
20 year old self
well i was a real screwup at 20 so i
mean
i've got i would probably have reams and
reams and reams of things to say
to my 20 year old self but i guess um
the number one thing i would tell my 20
year old self is
you have a problem with anxiety and
depression
you need to get help for it your life is
going to suck until you get that help
and then your life's going to get a lot
better
so go do that now so i guess just
identifying that i had that problem
was i wish i'd been able to
identify and act on it earlier
how did you do that actually andy how
did you how did you achieve that
um betterment of yourself well um
you know my main problem is anxiety i
mean i had real problems with depression
when i was in my 20s but as i got older
the depression just kind of
became anxiety instead and
you know throughout the 90s and stuff if
you if you wanted to get help for
anxiety
it was generally like you'd be told oh
here do some breathing exercises or
something like that which is kind of
like bringing a bucket of water to a
forest fire
it's just you know useless um
or or just suck it up you baby you know
kind of
advice but then um it's actually when
the martian came out and it got popular
and i was horribly afraid to fly
i i'm still am but whatever um
i had a huge fear of flying and i was
saying no to you know people would
invite me to one place or another and i
said no no no
but then nasa invited me to johnson
space center for a week of vip
tours and i'm like i have got to do this
right i cannot i can't i i need i want
to do this
and so i i said like all right maybe i
can get some pills that'll knock me out
you know to be on a plane so i started
talking to a doctor
a psychiatrist about that and um
she said okay we can work on that but
also you know
let's work on the you know persistent
generalized anxiety that you definitely
have you know
and so she she she ultimately gave me
pills that
let me fly and she's like that's great
but i also want to
deal with the long-term anxiety so i
guess what happened was i went to a
doctor for one thing
and she said i'll take care of that
thing but also you have this other
problem
and let's work on that and so
um she did and she gives me uh now i
have like
long-term anti-anxiety meds
that i take and they help a lot they've
really improved the quality of my life
it's not like this magic thing
it's just things are now manageable you
know
and i do therapy every week which is
if you broke your leg you wouldn't be
surprised that you have to do physical
therapy as part of your recovery that's
exactly right i just started doing
therapy
as as part of the podcast i have a
sponsor now
who does therapy and i was like ah much
i don't need to do therapy
but i was like i don't sponsor something
unless i actually try it
so that's why i'm doing these roman blue
pills i'm taking these bloopers i'm just
kidding i'm not doing those
but i can say i'm going to do this
online therapy and i have resistance to
it because i can solve my own problem
but i've been doing online therapy
through this i'm not going to mention it
because this isn't an ad
but um but i but i said to myself you
know
i go to a trainer on occasions i mean
you can't tell from this
massive physical specimen you see before
but you know we have trainers for we
have coaches we have you know all sorts
of things
why not do that as you say if you hurt
your leg you'd go to a freaking doctor
and this is just like a coach so i i i
think you're incredibly
you know courageous but but i think it's
in your self-interest to do it right
it's my one little i don't know you know
for some reason i guess you get a soap
box handed to you as soon as you're
famous
but this is my quote-unquote cause is to
i guess to try to design
de-stigmatize anxiety and depression and
just
just if you tell if you tell somebody oh
man i
broke my leg people are like oh that
sucks man sorry to hear that
but if you tell people you're like
suffering from chronic depression or
anxiety there's a little bit of a stigma
still to it
and so i you know if i can do anything
to destigmatize it
then that's good and you know
by just kind of saying like hey
everybody i've got this problem
one of the most comforting things for me
ever was uh red um
reading um carrie fisher's autobiography
uh
was it something drinks drinking wishful
drinking
is what it's called and she's hilarious
or her the book is
funny as hell but also it's just it made
me feel good to see
you know carrie fisher's problems with
like bipolar disorder
and it showed me oh hey you can be kind
of a little bit broken on the inside
and still be incredibly successful and
beloved by everyone you know that's
carrie fisher
right yeah and a sad analog to that is i
came within a
i came within two weeks of meeting her
and i wanted to tell her that
i wanted to tell her how much her book
affected me
and but she died um about two weeks
before a convention we were both gonna
be at
ah that's brutal yeah ah that's that's
awful yeah i once got to
almost got to meet herman woke who lives
not far from here and i always wanted to
be i'll meet him
he died like a couple weeks before i got
to meet him but
it's interesting that you mentioned all
this andy because may our right now is
mental health awareness month
this is a huge service that you do and
you know i've always
loved it's hard to believe that you know
you could have even more
appreciation and respect than i already
did but andy i want to thank you so much
for your uh for sharing your time and
being a friend of the arthur c clarke
center here
in uc san diego you're you're always
welcome here your money's always welcome
no i'm just kidding of course i'm just
kidding andy um your bitcoin that your
blockchain i thought that's what we're
going to say is on your monolith
[Music]
coin um anyway andy thank you so much
for coming on the show i wish you all
the best of success and abundance
and and and serenity too take time for
yourself and i hope we can get together
again i always love being in your
presence
someday after the apocalypse best of
luck eddie take care
all right thank you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you